so hi my name is Katya Skadden I'm being
sponsored by rutgers university to come
here and i apologize i'm not using the
standard Mathematica slideshow format
seems to be so prevalent here I have to
use a PowerPoint unfortunately but
hopefully we can get around that or
we're going to focus in on today or
something called the descending value
serial dictatorship I struggled trying
to find a really good title for my talk
because not a lot of people would really
want to come to something that says
optimal matching algorithm doesn't make
any sense so i used the best thing that
would appeal to as many people as
possible optimal trade algorithm because
technically that is what it is ok so in
game theory there's a small sub branch
called matching theory and what it is is
essentially this is dealing with trying
to allocate or trying to pair up players
with players what we're focused on today
is actually a small sub problem of that
but even though it's a little kind of a
sub branch of that it has wide
applications and in something called the
house allocation problem wherein you
have a bunch of objects and you have a
bunch of people who want those objects
and they have different preferences over
them who gets what and why so to give a
perfect analogy you have a table of
things and these objects could be
anything they don't have to be physical
objects they could be school slots out
of school they could be a kidneys if
you're in need of a kidney and you
really need a kidney you have
preferences over which kidney that you
get and you have different priorities
over that they could be slots in a
schedule they could be limited resources
for say a public school so like
computers chalkboards it could be
anything that you want the application
is very wide the problem the house
allocation problem with strict
preferences has already been solved very
satisfactorily strict preferences are
you are forcing all players
22 not be in difference so if you give
any two objects you have to prefer one
over the other and there's no way around
that right now until this comes along so
obviously this has a lot of problems
when you start talking about what
happens if you have ten thousand houses
or 10,000 chalkboards or something like
that wherein people are going to have in
differences you know any one of these
chalkboards would be great they're made
by the same company or we could say any
one of these kidneys would be fine you
know it's the same blood type it's
within a certain mile radius so I can
get it in a certain amount of time so
what happens when you have a whole lot
of people you're going to have in
differences and the suggestion up until
now is we have to arbitrarily break
these ties you could do it by a random
number generator these are real things
that people suggest to try to get around
this problem of indifference and
obviously that leads to a lot of
inefficiencies a lot of waste you could
actually find allocations where the most
number of people are going to get what
they want but the question is how do you
find that because we're dealing with
people so I realize that a lot of people
here are like computer science guys and
maybe they don't deal with you know
people but people are not as nice as
particles particles don't lie you could
argue against that but humans lie and if
you know ahead of time that well I'm
just going to find the allocation that
maximizes aggregate value and you find
out ahead of time I'm not going to get
what I want you can actually inflate the
value of some house and you can skew the
results and so how you find that
assignment is very important if you just
do it any other way like with a matrix
problem you can't rely on the preference
reports so like people are going to
submit their preferences to you like I
prefer this I prefer that I prefer that
if you just do a matrix problem you
can't perfectly rely on those preference
profiles because humans are met they're
really really bad they're going to lie
if they can because that's what's best
for you
yes they have a little timer for me okay
so that's one of the big problems we
can't easily rely on people telling the
truth which means we have to be very
careful about how we find these
assignments okay before we begin though
why should we even bother using matching
theory why can't we just use a utility
function like we learn if we all went to
an economics class you say there's a
payoff function it could be a calculus
some really long three line calculus
problem where we just do a derivative
it's no problem well it can be very
complicated because people measure
payoff and very unique in individual
ways and so the recommendation has been
to try to approximate utility for
different people that can be really
tricky the nice thing about using a
matching Theory problem such as a house
allocation problem is there's no utility
function all you got to do is ask people
what do you want you measure your own
utility function like you you may not
understand someone's preferences but you
don't have to they'll just give you the
list of what they want it's very easy to
understand too because let's say like
I'm just a guy who owns some bar
somewhere and I'm looking to get some
beer or something I'm going to look at
that utility functions say what I don't
know any of that you know they're going
to scratch the heads but it's easy to
understand if you just say what do you
want in what order and why you know well
I prefer coors light and miller you know
those two brands would be great after
that bud light or whatever and they can
easily submit it and it's also as I said
before widely applicable you can use
your imagination so what situations
would be find limited resources that
have to go to a certain number of people
or entities for example where I come
from in Philadelphia we have a really
big budget crisis in our public school
system and you can witness all around
the center city there are these really
affluent schools with really rich kids
and they've got computers in every
classroom and you know they've got all
these resources art programs music
programs all these great teachers
they're all well paid everyone's very
happy and yet they keep getting more
off we keep dumping our money out where
it's not needed and then in center city
where I actually work you got these
really crumbling crumbling public
schools but nothing coming in and even
less coming in like they're they're
taking the health health benefits away
from the teachers and so a problem like
this would be pretty useful because we
can actually say well what do you want
well the affluent schools will say well
we don't need more computers we don't
need more money although they might say
that they do we would need more lawn
care or something like that whereas
people from center city would say we
need more computers we need you know
better food for our you know school you
know for our students and whatever so
you don't need to mess with making a
utility function you could just say
outright I hear what you're saying
here's what we're going to try and do
for you so like I'm kind of jumping
around here why can't we just do this
like a matrix problem we've got
preferences let's say we have
indifference no problem we just have a
big matrix problem well if you've got
people who are smart like me I would
look at that and say well I am from a
very crappy public school and I know for
a fact that I'm probably not going to
get what I want so I'm going to play
around with my preferences to try to
gain the system because I don't care
about other people I only care about
what I get so if I can inflate my
preferences to get something better
which I can do I will so you can't just
black box it another now you can get
around this by and this has been shown
in a paper you can get around this by
making preference profiles private
information however that lacks appeal
like if you're just sitting there and
you say well I can go with the free
market and to shop around on my own or I
can join this private market where we
all participate in trade with each other
in this particular case though I'm
trusting you know that I'm going to get
something I don't know exactly what I'm
going to get until it's already assigned
and by then I'm just going to be like
well I don't think I want to join you
know so there's not a lot of appeal for
just doing the black box matrix power
another problem is yet just shooting for
highest aggregate value doesn't
guarantee competitiveness so I know
we're talking about oh yeah I should
specify
this is a house allocation problem
technically this is trading and the
difference is that people start with
something that they own the one way that
you can turn a house allocation problem
into a housing market problem which is
where everything own something is you
just randomly allocate someone to some
you just randomly allocate items to
people and then you run the algorithm
that's why the house allocation problem
also has the name random assignment
problem but it's solved exactly the same
way and there's no efficiency loss or
what have you doing it the black box way
with this the matrix doesn't guarantee
competitiveness so if somebody brings
say let's stay we're talking about a car
market all right and I am going to get
to my computer program I'm watching my
time here let's say we're dealing with
cars we all bright we all have a car we
don't let's face it no one likes the car
that they currently have well we like
some other people's cars around here
what if we all traded right now well
raise your hand if you have a really
expensive car okay one guy has a real
expensive car raise your hand if you
have a used 2006 ford taurus maroon
that's me I drove here in that Ford good
old Ford wouldn't you want to get
anything that you want you want to be
able to get anything that you want
because you know in your heart that you
have the most valuable car on the rim
right but doing it the black box way
doesn't guarantee that you're going to
get what you want so you have two
options you can join this market and
take a risk you can take a gamble maybe
I'll get something but if you just go on
the free market guaranteed first person
you talked to they'll trade whatever for
your red Ferrari or whatever you have
right so we want to reward people for
bringing better items to the market so
the matrix problem just using it by n
matrix doesn't work so once again the
method by which we obtain the answer is
more important than the answer itself
okay I'm skipping through a lot of the
theory here because you want to actually
get to the really crazy programming part
what I have developed is something
called the descending value serial
dictatorship and this actually
off of a lot of theory that has already
been done but this is the only one of
its kind that's pretty much the best
thing out there right now so the mother
the one that spawned this is something
called the random serial dictatorship
what that is is everybody just randomly
orders themselves they all get in a line
in a hallway and they walk through a
door one at a time and the one the first
person who walks in looks at the table
of objects and he picks one thing that
he wants and says yes and then leaves
and then the second guy walks in and he
picks something that he wants from
whatever's available and then he leaves
over time people are going to have less
and less items to choose from so people
have generally steered clear of the
random serial dictatorship because they
think it's unfair which is true because
what if the what a few sir with your red
Ferrari I assume it's a red Ferrari what
if it's randomly ordered uniform random
distribution and you're last in line do
you want to join the market that does
that that might do that no because you
can just go to the free market and be
like I'm not going to join this because
it's too risky I want to get anything
that I want no problem where this comes
into play is we don't just randomly
order people we make sure that the
person who brought the red Ferrari is
near the front of the line and the
person who brought the ford taurus which
is me I'm going to be way in the back
now we're going to do a little bit of
randleman if you're red Ferrari is
closed in value to someone else's Jaguar
or whatever we're going to random the
order between you but it still remains
that you're near the front of the line
because you get whatever you want
because you brought the best item here
you can get whatever you want that's
what makes a competitive since I
unfortunately brought the worst item
here my maroon ford taurus i'm going to
be in the back I got a deal with the
pickings so how it works is one person
the first person walks in takes what he
wants and then leaves and we keep doing
this over and over and over if at any
point someone walks into the room and
sees nothing that he wants he keeps the
thing that he started with so there's no
risk of you getting a bad assignment he
keeps the thing that he started with he
quits he leaves he goes home and then
everybody orders himself
roughly the way they did before and then
they do it again we keep doing this
until everybody's assigned so the great
news is remember the matrix we had to
keep every all the Preferences private
information because this is strategy
proof we can make preference profiles
public knowledge so I'm going to try and
incorporate some mathematica here what
that means is if you have cloud
programming you can just say all right
what are everybody's preferences right
now you can bring it up and you can
actually run this program ahead of time
to see roughly what you're going to get
you can decide whether or not you want
to join that was something you couldn't
do with the matrix problem but here
theoretically you can't change your
order around you are basically going to
get what you're going to get and yeah
now back to the thing all right back to
the algorithm let's say man with red
Ferrari what's your name by the way sir
Carl all right so you let's say you
gather up your top choices you're the
first one in line you can have anything
you want let's say you gather up all
your top choices you're okay with any
one of those any one of those would be a
great choice all right which one should
you pick where this is different from
the random serial dictatorship which is
randomly picks one we say you're going
to pick the one out of that group that
is of least value to all people who go
after you that way you are more likely
to give other people behind you
something that they want so you know
let's say you love that blue Jaguar or
whatever not a lot of people like that
blue Jaguar they like everything else
there but the blue Jaguar but that's
still a top choice for you you're going
to get that blue Jaguar and everyone
else is going to be like yes I got
something that I wanted that's great and
that's essentially what it is you're
going to choose something that is of
least value to people who go after you
you can have them because of strategy
proof you can have them run this
algorithm ahead of time to see if they
want to join you can see where they
stand where they stack with other people
and it's a lot of information and if
you're a consumer that's really good you
can still back out at the very end ok
now let's run before we go into that
let's run the algorithm itself so here
we're just going to show off how fast it
is we're going to start with a very
simple 50 player game so I've randomly
generated a game with 50 players the
preference sets vary between two and
five and we say houses in honor of the
original name of the problem called the
housing market problem but it doesn't
have to be houses with the number of
houses in a preference set varying
between three and seven so top choice
cannot have more than seven houses
cannot have less than three houses and
they could have first second choices
third fourth and fifth twists so if we
want to actually see what the preference
profiles are of each player this is
essentially what it is and the way we
read it is player a one who brought car
a one or house a one you know this
roughly the same their initial endowment
is the same as their personal name their
top choice is either a 10 a 16 or a 47
their second choice is either one of
these is fine as a second choice a 17 8
30 28 34 and so on and so forth for 50
players so it's really fast for 50
players and the way that we have found
it is 46 players got first choice three
players got second choice one person is
unassigned took about nine point eight
seconds here as the trade who gets what
and why so like player a 49 got a 43 if
you look that's going to be a top choice
most likely and then pour a 19 he's got
stewie has to give what he started with
no problem but that's not very
impressive a 50 player game is not very
exciting let's see what happens if we
make it a thousand players and you can
actually you can actually do this very
quickly because the descending value 0
dictatorship is computationally very
simple just one person going in and
picking a picking up a car that's
available and then leaving you don't
have to go through graphs you
have to do depth-first scans or anything
like that it's pretty easy so a thousand
players this time the preference sets
vary between two and five the number of
houses in a preference set vary between
30 and 70 if you have a thousand cars or
houses or slots in is scheduled to
choose from yeah you're probably going
to be a little bit more indifferent
because a lot of them are going to be
the same I mean if you have more houses
you're going to be a little bit more
indifferent but you can run this the
same way with a bunch of misers who are
just like I only want three out of a
thousand my top choice is only three you
know but odds are good that if you keep
adding more players or adding more items
there's going to be more indifference so
what's going on here we aren't actually
creating something called the side worth
function what that is is we are trying
to basically find the value of what a
top choices replacing a real number
value on what a top choice should be
we're placing a real number valium what
a second choice should be third
preference fourth preference and a fifth
preference now we're placing a side
worth value on each player so how do we
determine value here doesn't have to be
monetary we're going to do this by
voting more or less how many first
preferences does this red Ferrari get
how many second preferences does this
Ferrari get how many third preferences
does this Ferrari get and what have you
and we order it like this now
randomization patterns basically if your
value your side worth is closed
determined by a certain very special
type of epsilon which took a very long
time to find if it's close and value we
random the order and in that way you
cannot mess around with that other
person's side worth by deflating or
inflating their value you're still going
to be randomized between him and her him
or her setting up the algorithm you know
this doesn't take very long thanks less
than two minutes let's see if you guys
like I don't know if anybody's
interested but I printed up some
handouts I didn't think there'd be this
many people honestly I thought there'd
be like five but you know I there's a
bunch of them here there's a
mathematical model that explains what's
going
and on there's nice laymen descriptions
of what's going on also some examples a
compete on me all right so it's still
running a little bit here and we're
creating the matrix now I compete a
competitive algorithm that's out there
right now which is being used in a
business is something called the top
trade cycle algorithm which has been
around since the 70s this only works
again when you have strict preferences
no two items can be equal in value this
guy's using it as a business which is
fine it's very very time consuming
unfortunately it's very time consuming
right I have my timer here three minutes
it says not 53 he's making a ton of
money off of it however we have this
algorithm has advantages I can actually
publish my preferences he could too i
have indifference on my side which is
huge especially when you have a large
number of players and I'm guaranteed to
get within a certain amount of noise
obviously because there's a little
randomness they're very very close to
highest aggregate value all right this
calculation took me roughly maybe 150
seconds or so 997 players got top choice
out of a thousand three players got
second choice this algorithm is very
impressed no one was on assigned here
which is nice we could run this again
with very mazzoli like uncle scrooge's
you know where it's like I only want
free it'll still get roughly 900 I've
run this like a bazillion times not a
big deal but all these are our trade
cycles so I mean obviously this is a
little useless as far as a picture is
concerned if we wanted to actually look
up what's going on here a one gets a 872
810 gets a 921 so on and so forth we
could export this and yeah that's
essentially what that is and now of
course in the handout I actually have a
5,000 player game
we're in just like this one it's like
the number of houses in a preference set
vary between 40 and 50 if you want you
can take a look but 4970 four players
get top twists which is like ninety-nine
point nine percent oh yeah I got what I
wanted so I've got about a minute left
before questions and conclusion if this
thing is widely used this thing could
change the way that we do things for
example right now we're having problems
anywhere really with developing
countries allocating resources to
developing nations right now all these
NGOs are out there and well-meaning and
they have a bunch of coats they have a
bunch of food they have a bunch of water
but they work independently and
separately a lot of people have
complained that villages say in
Afghanistan get things that they don't
need so their villages way up in the
north and the mountains and they get
coats obviously if they lived there they
already have the coats but the NGO
really cares and they drop the coats and
it's not very coordinated not efficient
but these algorithms like that exist
like this can get those resources where
they need to go they can do it and
guarantee that people can't lie to
change their preferences so you know for
a fact that people who report their
preferences those preferences are going
to be true and they're not going to be
skewed or anything like that another
thing I mean there's a lot of game
theory involved here this assignment is
stable which is a big deal it means that
no one is going to change their
assignment afterwards and now it's zero
okay it's stable no one's going to
change the assignment afterwards you
don't have to enforce like tie-break you
don't have to enforce people breaking
ties because you want people to
basically report there in differences in
whatever and we actually want people to
collude believe it or not so one thing
that you might be thinking when you look
at this is man couldn't people work
together to gain the system actually the
theory is we want people to collude if
more people collude and make their
preferences work too you know
to help out their coalition that
actually improves stability believe it
or not individually yes it is strategy
proof and yeah we still want to keep
preferences public and yes we do want
people to decide whether or not they
want to join so that means they have to
program you know run the program on
their own without Mathematica and they
can decide for themselves